[Musique]
la fabrication additive qu'on surnomme
souvent l'impression en trois dimensions
sur une technologie qui est de plus en
plus utilisés de plus en plus implantés
dans des entreprises en partie ici mais
on pourrait en faire plus d'où la
création le mois dernier du carrefour
québécois de la fabrication additive on
va parler tous avec marie pierre
ippersiel lé pdg du pôle de recherche et
d'innovation en matériaux avancés au
québec donc primates québec bonsoir
madame hyper ciel bon sens et permet on
va rappeler pour le bénéfice de tous de
manière très générale la fabrication
additive ce que c'est dans le fond
l'impression 3d communément appelée
c'est en fait une technique de
fabrication qui va procéder par l'ajout
d'une couche de matière à la fois donc
cédé couche par couche qui s'accumulent
on peut utiliser différents matériaux
que ce soit du plastique que ce soit de
la peau métallique mais c'est la façon
dont ça fonctionne contrairement à
d'autres techniques de fabrication
qu'ils et elles vont procéder par
retrait de la matière donc dû découper
puis je vous dire simplement et tout ça
est automatisée avec fichiers numériques
ces programmes il règle générale ça se
fait de façon ça a l'air facile et c'est
une technologie qui existe depuis quand
même un certain temps et on a
l'impression que l'utilisation en
entreprise ne fait que commencer on en
est où là en ce moment au québec par
exemple en fait serment comme vous le
dites je pense au début des années 80 au
japon plusieurs ont développé des des
imprimantes la période 90 2010 est
importante pour développer différentes
technologies parce qu'il faut comprendre
la fabrication de 6 une famille de
différentes technologies et au québec à
l'heure actuelle je voudrais que est un
peu partout dans le monde les secteurs
de l'aérospatiale des sciences de la vie
technologies médicales utilisent déjà
assez bien ce genre de technologie et au
québec si vous permettez on a quand même
beaucoup de force à cet égard on a des
leaders très important au niveau de la
fabrication de poudres métalliques par
exemple on pense à apc à blainville
techno sherbrooke rio tinto cinquième
plus bas il ya beaucoup de joueurs ici
au québec et donc pourquoi la création
de ce carrefour québécois de la
fabrication additive on veut amener sa
plus loin on va mener ce plus loin et je
prends un peu de recul pour rappeler un
peu d'où viennent initiative en 2019
on a vraiment entament une démarche pour
avoir le premier le tout premier livre
blanc sur la fabrication du style
primant à travailler ça avec plusieurs
partenaires institutionnels industriels
et on s'est dit bon on a des forces on a
des faiblesses par exemple comment on
peut aider davantage d'entreprises à
adopter cette technologie là parce que
je vous le disais tantôt on a beaucoup
de producteurs de poudre donc l'intrant
qui exporte en grande partie leur
production alors si on veut créer
davantage de 1,6 de richesse par dont on
s'attend à pouvoir l'a transformé ici
donc enjeux défis et au delà de tout ça
on a identifié plusieurs mesures qui
permettraient à cet écosystème lot de
prendre son envol mais surtout quand on
a sondé les entreprises on avait on
sentait le besoin d'avoir une espèce de
guichet unique bon c'est très galvaudé
comme approche mais être en mesure de
retrouver à un endroit entre autres les
programmes les services mais également
d'être en mesure de pouvoir avoir une
meilleure visibilité sur ce qu'ils
pouvaient eux même pu offrir et donc
pour pour des entreprises qui sont
intéressés à
naviguer près du carrefour quel genre de
service on peut aller chercher est ce
que c'est vraiment les aider à implanter
cette technologie dans les entreprises
dans un premier temps c'est clair que
les membres que l'on recherche c'est
tout ce qu'ils font partie de l'offre
entre autres mais pour tous ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cette technologie là
ils pourront avec un moteur de recherche
trouver l'offre disponible en fonction
technologie de matériaux peu importe
très variés mais au delà de sauf être
capable pour eux de d'identifier aussi
l' expertise en recherche parce que le
québec est très fort au niveau de 8 des
matériaux avancés mais également dans la
question de la fabrication d'ici donc
identifier les ressources pour les
entreprises qui souhaitent utiliser le
carrefour être aussi en mesure de
partager des expériences des
connaissances pense que la volonté de
vouloir mutualiser tout ça est important
on a fait l'effort et ça va se
poursuivre évidemment de documenter des
histoires d'une réussite des études de
cas les études qu'on nous dise ok pour
telle pièce quel matériau pourrait
utiliser donc essayé avec ses contenus
là de convaincre d'autres entreprises
d'adopter cette technologie qu'est ce
que ça change pour les entreprises
d'adopter cette technologie si ces
révolutionnaires on peut pas s'en passer
ça va changer le monde mon ami personnel
en fait il ya beaucoup d'avantagés
technologiques à la fabrication d'outils
ça nous permet par exemple de passer
rapidement de la conception à la
production pièce ça nous permet aussi de
produire des produits des produits à
géométrie variable donc plus complexe
plus léger et surtout ça permet dans
plusieurs cas de réduire le nombre de
pièces je pense à mon tuyau
d'échappement de mon auto par exemple
grosso modo c'est une vingtaine de
pièces si on le fabrique à partir ou
avec la fabrication du si on peut lui on
peut le faire avec une seule pièce donc
la réduction pièce est importante ça
c'est une chose donc l'avantagent le
potentiel technologique mais si on
regarde aussi d'un point de vue
économique il faut le voir il ya un
potentiel de marché
heureuse qui est une référence pardon
nous dit que par exemple il ya eu une
croissance entre 2010 et 20 21 d'un
potentiel de marché d'un milliard à
15mhz phénoménal c'est très peu de temps
dans ma famille personne mais c'est vers
des rides il ya des enjeux
environnementaux avec sa également on
utilisera en matière et par exemple
plutôt que d'avoir puis jeudi
grossièrement des exemples un inventaire
incroyable de pièces dont on peut les
faons sur mesure alors il ya des
avantages évidemment c'est très
inspirant je suis certaine qu'on veut en
entendre parler de nouveaux merci
beaucoup de nous avoir visité madame
personnes merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh
[Musique]